[Musique]
qui lors d'une balade n'a jamais eu
envie de cueillir les fleurs et les
plantes souvent on ne sait pas quoi en
faire et certains réalisent les herbiers
de petit livre regroupant nos
découvertes une petite création que
mélanie a décidé de réaliser bonjour mme
hélène bonjour cabinet oui avec les
beaux jours de belles fleurs et feuilles
apparaissent du fils de résister même si
un herbier ça peut se faire toute
l'année
alors la première étape bien sûr c'est
de collecter les trésors on s'équipe de
nos chaussures et on part se balader
moi je les fais pas plutôt que ce matin
il faut bien sûr ouvrir les yeux et
ramasser ce qu'il nous plaît et pour la
suite en revanche il faut un petit peu
de matériel comme toute activité
manuelle finalement du papier cartonné
des feuilles blanches une paire de
ciseaux du scotch de la ficelle et pour
ceux qui veulent un herbier
perfectionner pourquoi pas du scotch
décoratifs et des feutres alors la
première étape importante pour le voit
c'est de faire sécher aplatir nos
récoltes on dispose les feuilles et
fleurs entre deux feuilles de brouillon
on place dessus un livre lourd et on
patiente alors ça peut être assez
rapidement en général ça dure entre 1 et
2 jo et une fois que c'est fait sur une
feuille blanche que j'ai choisi moi de
coupé en deux on scotch les feuilles
très important ensuite on note le nom de
la petite plante et pourquoi pas la date
et le lieu avec un petit commentaire
aussi pour que se crée un petit souvenir
elle sans oublier bien sûr la décoration
et oui comme tout petit livre il faut
une couverture alors j'ai choisi des
teintes marron une très claire et une
foncé j'ai glissé à l'intérieur mais
feuille blanche on pis pour créer une
pochette on colle après j'ai tout
rassembler avec une ficelle vous allez
le voir sur les images la séquence je
colle je fais ma couverture
voilà j'ai fait des trous et ensuite on
décore alors on peut dessiner on peut
coller certaines aussi de nos écoles
vous allez voir c'est ce que j'ai fait
et puis on peut aussi écrire bien sûr
dessus mon herbier pour être sûr de ne
pas le perdre
et voilà c'est terminé il faut penser à
mettre aussi des feuilles blanches
supplémentaires pour compléter lherbier
quand on va faire d'autres balades et on
a en autre rendez vous également à noter
aimé parce que si on hésite à se lancer
c'est pas toujours facile au tout début
la chapelle art contemporain de
clairefontaine en yvelines organise un
an
dès l'âge de 4 ans les réservations là
par contre sont obligatoires comptez 12
euros demandés merci mélanie vous avez
vous savez donc ce qu'il vous reste à
faire pour votre prochaine balade dans
un parcours en forêt merci encore